[Musique]
brett don't panic
bah oui toi non l'idée c'est vraiment
faire des choses et lisieux
je m'appelle johnson richesse
co-créateur du récent corded à mourir
c'est vraiment 5 qu'est ce qu'on a fait
aujourd'hui c'est qu'on a juste mis les
oiseaux entière dans le chaudron on l'a
couvert actuels ou qui on la cuit je
serai sabraise assez peu comme être
capable de séparer les victimes pour les
volailles savait vraiment dépendre du
grand bar c'est un gros poulet ça peut
prendre deux ans d'un petit pintade par
contre c'est comme si je dois vous le
regardez c'est assez simple quand tu es
capable de les filocher j'ai près les
raisons que l'on suggère cette technique
lassé de l'éviter du gaspillage et que
c'est très simple à chez des volailles
des poulets ou quoi ça soit entière
c'est plus gagnante aura d'iran prix que
genre acheter des choses déjà on découpe
les poitrines sort quasiment comme tout
en un morceau alors tu actuellement un
programme déjà cuites tous que tu peux
faire c'est un genre de rêver avec la
bouillon qui à chicken pilaf costa ou
poulet casseroles de pente tout la même
transformation mais avec des jeux peu le
mélanger avec d'autres ingrédients pris
des options deviennent de plus en plus
exponentielle
aujourd'hui on va préparer des recettes
avec trois ingrédients volaille tard
votre pognon avec ses trois combinaisons
des réserves
on peut quand même faire en plus variés
des deux choses où si tu as comme jeu
seul coffret go tu peux cuisiner ça sur
plusieurs journées puis ça va pas goûté
la même chose à chaque jour que ça va
être différente que tu vas pas être tom
suis tanné de manger des sandwichs de
poulet
on va prendre les oignons les carottes
on va aller couper des très petits
morceaux qu après ça on va aller sauter
dans un cas d'école pendant vraiment
longtemps ça va enlever tous louent
excellente
il a recommencé à caraméliser après ça
on va déglacer avec le bouillon de
poulet il ya certainement des aromates
et des épices l'effiloché si tu les
laisses ans de son bouillon c'est
désirable alors le fait que ça décidera
ce qu'il fallait pour aller dans l'huile
ça devient croustillant très vite on va
cuire les pâtes puis on va ré assembler
sur l'assiette
après ça si tu as du fromage dans ton
frigo cool sites en europe à ses
parieurs
alors la deuxième chose qu'on va
proposer ses suppôts voulez ça c'est
vraiment simple affaire relativement
gros match si tu veux et où avec un
bouillon et du poulet déjà fait c'est
quand même vraiment pas long à se rendre
à qom sur complète alors on va couper
les oignons les carottes
on va juste les sautés légèrement encore
tu ajoutes les aromates que tu veux que
tu as chez toi que tu aimes ça peut être
des épices comme ça peut être juste du
sel on coule le bouillon de poulet par
dessus on cuit jusqu'à que les légumes
sont cuits
on ajoute le poulet effiloché dans la
soupe on après on assaisonne ces prêts
après que tu as la base de faits cette
soupe lolita tu mens tu peux le faire
qu'à moins de 30 minutes
alors s'il en reste du karaté du poulet
puis des oignons qui s'attend pas de
faim quelque chose de chaud on va juste
faire une salade de carottes râpées avec
les poulets effiloché dedans c'est un
salad très simple mais vraiment bon puis
après ça on va juste assaisonner puis
mais desagneaux marrainée par dessus
c'est un autre façon où l'on peut
utiliser des restes mais tu veux pas
nécessairement manger la même chose
les années ont mariné dans cette recette
là honnêtement ça peut être n'importe
quel vinaigre que tu as deux parties au
karting écoulée par dessus des années
ont repris
[Musique]
ces trois ingrédients là avec des
féculents tu tu pouvais être parent
vieillissant chose alors dans chaque
semaine qui coûte différentes pipototal
mais depuis quand même bien mûri
les recettes sont réfléchies de la façon
de garder le coup la plus beau possible
de dépenser les gens pendant leur par
personne par rapport et quand même temps
quelque chose vraiment bon hit minutieux
[Musique]